hey welcome back for those of you who
weren't here for the keynote I'm master
Gerson and I'm the lead designer for the
c-sharp language so the next hour we
kind of spent talking about some of the
things that we recently added to c-sharp
and some of the things that we're
planning to add and hopefully there'll
be time for a few questions from you
guys as well so when we look at the
stack the stack overflow survey that
goes out every year to developers I
always like to open that up and see how
are we doing with c-sharp
here's the top many languages I I've
sliced out the ones that I don't
consider to be programming languages and
this is what you is what you get so if
you look at the most popular programming
languages the ones that most people use
or at least most developers who
responded to the survey you can see that
c-sharp is prominently figured there's a
lot of people using c-sharp and we're
happy to note that more and more of them
are using c-sharp cross-platform on many
different platforms we also look at the
most loved programming languages this is
where the smaller languages get to play
because this is measured in terms of the
percentage of users who would like to
continue using that language and we're
happy to see that c-sharp is represented
here as well so we are in a in good
shape in terms of both people using
c-sharp but also liking it and not just
doing it because they have to sometimes
it's interesting to look at some of the
other languages that are on here if you
think about other languages that are on
both of these top tens
pythons being there along with c-sharp
for a couple years
last year typescript joined so yeh go
Microsoft you also see f-sharp down
there is one of the most loved though
it's not quite made the top ten in terms
of usage yet this year a couple more
joined the Swift language essentially
has been loved for a while now rose to
higher usage and the JavaScript language
a lot of people
very happy with the JavaScript language
now so that was a little baffling to us
but I think that there's a common trend
among many of these languages which is
that we we all take quite an aggressive
approach to evolution and making sure
that there are all the tools in the box
for for people to use in professional
development so that leads us to what is
the strategy for c-sharp actually what
are we thinking about what are the the
goal posts that we we use when we think
about what to do with c-sharp the
language itself as well as the platform
around it and that's actually a link
here which you can go click that takes
you to where we post our language
strategy for c-sharp visual basic and F
sharp so you can can compare I pulled
out some of the main phrases here for
for C sharp which is first and foremost
we'll keep growing C sharp so whenever
there are evolving needs whenever there
are new scenarios that we want to
embrace and whenever there's new
technology or new ideas in the language
space that would fit well into c-sharp
we will completely embrace it and we'll
also innovate aggressively ourselves so
we're not afraid to sometimes take the
lead and introduce a new feature a new
kind of feature that other languages can
then use to to move their needle as well
as you've seen that several times over
the years with c-sharp it's important
for us to recognize that we have a very
broad set of developers we have great
diversity in the developer base and so
therefore we have to focus our
improvements mostly on things that
benefit all developers or most
developers sometimes they benefit them
directly and a few times they benefit
them more indirectly as you will see in
the in the features I'm going to show
later in this talk and then last but
definitely not least we'll continue to
empower the ecosystem in other words to
to improve the influence and the
dialogue that the broader c-sharp
community
as on the evolution of the language
itself so this is clearly something
that's evolved over the years now we're
completely open-source and if we get
time we can go and look a little at that
as well later in the talk third language
to sign itself is open source and
there's a daily dialogue with with the
community rather than you know every two
or three years when we would release a
new version and and hope that people
liked it so this has been a great trend
for us and that's something that we're
quite determined to to keep evolving
that relationship with a community that
said we also want to balance this with
continuing what we think is one of the
successes of c-sharp
which is that we we try to exercise very
strong stewardship of the language and
the design decisions so that there's
there's one body of designers that have
been in it for a long time and it can
guarantee continuity and coherence of
the language as it evolves so it's not
sort of a design by committee democracy
kind of of design environment there's
still a little group of us that are
making the ultimate decisions and making
sure that all the people who were more
interested in using c-sharp and less
interested in evolving it that they get
you know a solid experience going
forward and they get a well curated
language if you will so that's kind of
our mindset that we that we apply when
we go into language design which would
uh which we do several times a week so
here are kind of the main phrases from
there keep drawing C sharp innovate
aggressively benefit all developers
empower the ecosystem and show strong
stewardship so let's talk about some of
the reason than coming versions of
c-sharp so over the last year in a bit
we released no less than three point
releases of c-sharp that's kind of a new
thing for us to have point releases we
usually have major releases every couple
of years that have major numbers like
something zero and in fact when we got
to six we figured we were never going to
have anything but or releases and we
started talking about it just a c-sharp
six not C sharp six oh but with seven
that changed
we realized that we had a we had evolved
so much in our process that we were able
to ship more often and also we didn't
want to hold back value that you know
developers could get sooner if they
wanted to while at the same time
recognizing that smaller steps maybe
shouldn't be something that everyone was
forced to to use so we reintroduced this
and divide between major and minor
versions we also had some specific
scenarios that that span across all of
the dotnet layers if you will that were
related to framework and runtime work as
well as the language work and we wanted
to ship those as a package and so this
was a good time to exercise doing sort
of out-of-band releases of c-sharp if
you will so that's what c-sharp 7 1 72
and 73 were about more specifically the
sort of core there couple of like
driving themes here the core driving
theme is one about safe efficient code
so this is a feature set that is
primarily targeted at people doing
somewhat lower level programming in
c-sharp
so they're sort of the direct
beneficiaries if you will but because
they're building the lower levels of
what everyone else builds on there's
direct benefit certainly in terms of the
improved performance that those
frameworks can get but sometimes also
the abstractions that they can offer a
better because of these features so it's
something that has a positive impact on
everyone even though many people don't
need to relate to it so much so we'll
spend our our time talking about seven
one two three here primarily focusing on
these safe efficient features and I'll
show some demos I did a short one in the
in the keynote earlier this morning if
you saw that but there were various AV
difficulties there so I'll try to get
that whole demo flow a little more
expand at this time and show all those
features there also just general
improvements things that used to be not
allowed that are now allowed such as
using delegate or enum as constraint as
constraints in generics and many more
things and they're also the the usual
set of nice abbreviations that let you
write things shorter than you used to so
I have a link at the end of the deck
where you can go and look at our Docs
at dr. microsoft.com and they generally
have very good but they do have very
good summaries of what's new and in the
individual versions and so on I
encourage you to go and look at all the
things I don't explain here or even once
I do and kind of get the details on it
so then that's C sharp 8 which is our
next planned version that's coming up
sometime later and the main theme here
is for it just to be magical like this
is where we want to do actually a not
very close tight ly related set of
features that all are bigger and have
more of an impact on how you program and
hopefully take your development to a new
level so I allowed myself one unicorn
today here and this is it so before we
dive into that though let's take that
thrower look at C sharp 7 1 7 2 & 7 3 so
let me go into Visual Studio and start
out with this particular project here so
I want to talk about the improvements we
made around ref so some of you may have
noticed there's a ref in the language
you probably don't use it very much but
I'm going to show how several
improvements and new things here can
make working with structs a lot easier
and a lot safer like give you a lot of
places where you don't need to reach for
unsafe code for instance and pointers
and then building on that we'll talk
about the new span of T features in a
minute
so ref is really a feature for passing
things by reference and since objects
are already passed by reference like you
never copy an object to somewhere else
you always just pass a reference to it
this is primarily interesting for
trucks so if you're trying to improve
your performance
avoid allocations by using structs then
you'll want to use these features and if
you don't because you were at a higher
level then be thankful that somebody
further down are doing it like the
improvements you saw in a tech empower
benchmark for instance in nikinoo those
derive among many other things from from
starting to adopt these features here so
just as a reminder I have a little
program here that has a method that
takes two int and returns an int which
is one of one of the two that I've got
in and then it mutates them and and
writes a few things out and let's do
this by ref instead of passing the int
by value will now pass refs to the intz
so you see that when I put the ref
modifier on the on the method here I get
a squiggle down here saying I'm not I'm
I'm asking for parameters by ref but I'm
not passing them by ref so the arguments
also in c-sharp ever since C sharp wanna
know have to have a ref modifier saying
hey you're passing you're not passing
the value that's in a and B you're
passing the actual variable a and B and
you're passing it to someone so that
they can change it and modify the
variables that you declared here and
that you see okay so that's been around
for a long time now one of the let me
just look at my cheat sheet here yes
so one of the things that you haven't
been able to do is to use extension
methods where this parameter the first
the receiver of the extension method was
a ref so that's something that we added
recently so you can now say this here
and then you get an extension method
that if I choose I can go and call it
with a as a receiver and now I need to
remove the first argument and I'm
passing it with a here in state so you
see in this case where I'm calling as a
receiver I don't have to say ref for the
usage of a here and we think that's
alright because when you're calling
things as an
since message you were kind of expecting
that to be able to mutate the receiver
so we think that sort of the visual cue
is good enough without having to sort of
massage the ref keyword into the syntax
here somewhere
so that's extension methods another
thing that we that we wanted to improve
was using refs without fear okay so I
talked about this this fear inducing
step of passing your actual variable to
someone else who might mutate it which
is the case here they actually do mutate
it but what if I want to pass let's say
it's not int but it's a big struct I
want to pass it by ref for efficiency
sake but I don't actually want them to
mutate it that's something that we then
went and added new features for in
c-sharp seven two so instead of a ref
parameter let's say we want four Y here
want to protect it against a mutation I
can pass it as an in parameter and now
that means that still pass by reference
but you can see them the method is no
longer allowed to mutate it so the
mutation of it is forbidden and that
means that the method here or the main
method here can safely pass it so I'm
going to so I don't get to use the ref
keyword anymore because I'm now passing
it by in so to speak so I can use the in
keyword instead still matching that the
using is a keyword match here and that
means you know I acknowledge that they
can see whatever changes I make to B but
they can't make any changes themselves
now that looks an awful lot like passing
things by value except that it's more
efficient and so we actually do allow
you to not even say the in keyword you
don't need to be warned in syntax that
you are passing something by in because
the people you're passing it to won't be
able to do anything with it you can
actually emit the in keyword altogether
and pass just the variable like that and
in fact if you do that you can even pass
something that's not a variable like 40
or let's just use 42 here and we will
automatically create a variable in the
background and pass it by as a read-only
ref to the to the mint
okay so so that's in parameters now a
thing that we introduced a little a
little while back is ref returns so I
actually want this method not just to
return the value of one of the variables
but to actually select one of the
variables and return the variable itself
so I can do that by returning by ref
okay so now I'm returning either in this
case I'm returning X by ref and I have
to acknowledge that by returning the ref
to the X variable here and that's fine
but here I'm still so I'm returning it
by ref but I'm still taking the value
and putting it into the C variable here
if I want if I want the ref itself the
reference to the variable I have to sort
of take the ref like I do when I pass a
ref parameter and then I have to declare
the variable as being a ref as well so
now C is no longer a variable holding an
int but it's a variable pointing to
another variable holding an int right
and which variable that is that comes
from the ref initializer here which is
whatever comes back from the or maybe
method so in this case you can see since
it returns a ref - its X parameter which
we passed the a variable for that then C
will actually be an alias to the a
variable and so when I when I increase
it here we can try running it when I
increase the variable here you can see
that the a variable changes as well so
there you go you can see that a and C
are aliases to the same variable here so
in general you have this idea that a ref
is sort of like a window onto another
variable whether you have some storage
and you have a window onto the storage
and if you use in instead of ref is the
windows closed you can see through it
but you can't reach through it and
manipulate the thing so is this open
window and closed window analogy that we
can we can exploit it a little further
down the line here
you can also actually make the thing
that comes back from a method read-only
so I could return a refereed only to int
here
and that makes the the caller not able
to mutate the variable that they get
back so here we get an error because I
am storing it as a ref and then mutating
it but I have to store it as a ref
read-only to promise that I won't mutate
it before the method call will let me
grab that ref and key hold on to it and
now I said I can't mutate it and so I
get a squiggle here when I try to do it
anyway and I have to I have to stop
doing that and the nice thing about that
is that if I didn't have read-only here
so let's just remove that for a second
and if I pass the X parameter by in now
I I have a X is a read-only thing and so
I'm not allowed to return it by to
return its ref to someone who might
mutate it and in order to keep the
contract the thing I promised here by
saying into X I have to also make it
read only when I return it back out
again in order for the squiggle there to
go away and then I can't mutate that one
either so you see how it all hangs
together the protection the extra
protection of in and of read-only kind
of flows through the whole thing and
guarantees that the only mutate things
that you that you want to now that was a
whole lot about ref and why is that
interesting well part of why it's
interesting is that in a subtle way ref
and refereed only a part of the span of
T story that was this framework runtime
and language feature set that we rolled
out recently and that is part of c-sharp
seven two and seven three so let's go
and have a look at span span is kind of
like ref but for a whole race for like
contiguous memory if you will so where a
ref is a window onto a single variable
as span is a window onto a whole array
or like a chunk of an array and let's
see that in action here so I have a I
have a program here where I create an
array initialize it and I write out all
the elements so let's go in and try to
play with span in this per
Graham and this is the demo that didn't
work out so well in the keynote this
morning and hopefully it works out
better today so if we're going to look
at array you can see there are a couple
of new extension methods one of them is
s span which lets me get a span from the
array whatever that means so a span
return to span of int let's grab that
span of int into it variable call it
span and now what we have is essentially
an alias for the array it's a window
onto the same elements and we can see
that by writing out the elements in the
span instead of the ones in the array
and you should be able to still see the
initialized values here from 0 to 9 even
though the even though I I took the span
if you will before I initialize the
array so if the span had copied over
values it would still be all zeros if
you want to further assure yourself of
it we can also turn it around and
actually initialize through the span and
write out the elements of the array and
you can see I'm by initializing through
the span I'm reaching through the window
and manipulating the array that the span
points to that it's an open window too
if you will and just like just like well
let's get to that in a second but one of
the things that you might want to think
about is what can you then do with this
ban well you can do many of the same
things and you can do with an array but
you can also do other things and one of
the things you can do is that you can
slice them so I can take a slice of a
span for instance from the 3rd element
and and five elements on from there and
what that returns me is another span
that's only two part of the array so
it's still to some of the same memory
locations but am but with but with some
of them sliced out and so if I if I
write out the elements of the slice here
you can see that I only get the ones
from 3 to 7
which are the ones that I sliced out but
I'm still looking at the elements that
only got initialized after I created the
slice so still no copying of the array
here and we can also modify through a
slice so I could do slice of 2 equals 42
and then actually write out the elements
in the span and you can see that
I modified the one that was the second
element from the slices point-of-view
but which is actually the fifth element
or sixth element depending on our
account of the of the underlying array
and the span that I created this slice
from so it all kind of works out windows
onto the same memory and you can imagine
how you can manipulate these in various
ways and have nice method signatures
that that pass refs and spans around
without copying the thing that's kind of
missing here still that was in the ref
story is if I pass a span to someone how
can I prevent them from modifying the
thing that the span refers to and
similar to ref read only is there's a
read-only span type that you can just
convert your span to and that prevents
modification so you can see that if I if
I make the slice read-only span and I
don't get to reach through the window
and manipulate it all right so that's
that that's the deal with the span here
there's one c-sharp ate feature that I'm
actually gonna that I can't show you
today we have shown it before but the
bits are currently in a state where I
can't demo it but is going to be quite
interesting in connection with this as
well as many other things and that is
that indexing in c-sharp it's kind of
basic you can pass like for instance to
an array you can you can or a span here
you can pass an int and you get that
number element one thing you can't do is
for instance say I want the third
element from last you have to do your
own math in order to compute based on
the length the current length of the
array or the span you have to compute
the third element from last so we're
introducing a little syntax to do that
it's not going to work here but I'm
going to type it anyway so we use the
little hat symbol to say from end
essentially and that's sort of that's
useful in and of itself but one of the
things that we then also want to use it
for is to introduce a notion of ranges
into the syntax of c-sharp and one of
the places where that will come in
really neat is for instance for the
slicing operator here instead of
having to call a method and giving these
parameters well we could just index the
span with a range from say three to
seven 3.7 or the 1i hat that was 3.8 or
maybe three dot dot the the third from
last or whichever combination of the
indexing and ranged in Texas you want
here and the ranges are also planned to
be open-ended optionally so you can say
3 dot dot from 3 to the end or you can
say from the beginning to 7 or you can
actually just say all of it so there's a
range that's open on both sides it just
means get me the whole thing um which is
you know something that you you might
want to do if you were for instance
slicing on multiple dimensions and some
of them you don't want to narrow in and
so it's a convenient syntax to not have
any of the any of the endpoints visible
here so that's something that we have a
prototype of and it's going into see
share bait but from here I want to go
back to I don't go over to another demo
and sort of move firmly into things that
we're doing in C share of eight
that's a demo of the nullable reference
types features that we are adding and
then after that we'll see some slides of
other features that are that are planned
to go into c-sharp eight right after I
type my password here so now you can get
to see how long my password is
there we go
luckily I didn't need to factor
authorization here I would have taken a
while so here is a this is on a remote
machine and that's because the the bits
aren't working on my machine right now
but this is an example of a program that
looks completely innocent and innocuous
but it's actually dangerous and this is
the the if you go through the the
program here you can say I have a person
or the first name and last name it's
Miguel I guess it's middle name and I
and I write it out and the method that
gets a middle name does exactly what
you'd expect it gets the middle name and
gets the link okay so that looks fine
and there no flashing warning signs but
if I compile and run it then you
probably won't be surprised because
you're probably a scarred as I am that
you will well once we're done compiling
we won't actually get the length of
Miguel's non-existing middle name we'll
get an one time exception
that's a null reference exception and
and that's something that's we've gotten
so used to but it's still very hard to
keep the null reference exceptions out
of our production code because we don't
have proper tools at development time to
kind of minimize the situations where we
accidentally run into a null this kind
of situation is is a little hard because
it's unclear who's to blame here is it
is the method here to blame for getting
the length of the middle name or is the
is the constructor to blame for putting
a null in there in the first place who
decides what the contract is shoot a
middle name should it probably be able
to be null or not so that's where we
figured it's time for some more
expressiveness in c-sharp and two to
have a feature that helps you deal with
that
and so let's go and look at that person
class and start from there there's a new
feature in town it gives you extra
warning so you kind of have to turn it
on and that feature is is nullable
reference types so in order to turn that
on I I use an attribute here so at the
module level I'll specify the attribute
non null types and that attribute what
it says is that with this attribute
we're going to start considering all
your reference types to be none nullable
and we're going to warn you if we see
you sticking nulls in them okay so we
are strengthening the contract around
all the reference types that are in your
code today saying from now on we're not
gonna let them be null any longer we're
not gonna give you errors but we're
gonna give you warnings to help you not
do that so hmm
obviously that can only be part of the
story but it's a pretty useful part of
the story and we'll get to the other
half in a little bit so what you see now
that I have that turned on I get a
warning on the person constructor here
that only initializes the first and last
name and the warning says you are not
initializing the none nullable property
middle name you are not making it not
null well I can go and fix that warning
real quick I can initialize it a middle
name equals null now I don't get the
warning anymore all right
I get another warning saying hey you
can't put a null in there either you
can't leave it all and you can't put it
all well what can I do then this is the
other half of the story well I can
declare to the world that it is supposed
to be null okay
so I can put a question mark on the
string type on this reference type just
like you already can with value types
and that is how I declare that the
middle name is in fact nullable it's
supposed to sometimes be null and
whoever consumes it better take that
into account they can't trust it to be
there the way that first name and last
name can be trusted because I always
initialize those so now you see the
warning went away on the initialization
here and even if I didn't have the
initialization I wouldn't get the
warning on the constructor because it
only cares if the none nullable
reference fields are in ich
so so far so good I owned up to my
nullity in in the surface area of the
type that I'm using how can I then make
use of that when I consumed it well you
see another warning here saying hey you
possibly dereferencing a null reference
here Peter midlane might be null yet
your dot lengthing it you should be
doing that well I guess they're right
okay since the since the surface area of
the type that I'm consuming is now has
now been detailed to specify the null
ability I no longer have any excuse here
when I'm consuming it I can't be in
doubt as to whether I need to handle
nulls or not
in any given case fact of the matter is
first names I don't need to handle nulls
middle names I do the the signature says
so and so now it's on me to fix this bug
now we didn't want to add new fancy
features to c-sharp for fixing this bug
like we wanted to be able to recognize
the ways that you already check for null
today so it should be that if if you
write null safe code the way you've
always done it then we will recognize
that and we won't give you warnings and
so that kind of leads us to introducing
this feature of a flow analysis that
will try to track the value of different
variables and properties and throughout
the the flow of a method and will try to
see where they can possibly not be null
and where they can't and where they
can't possibly be null we won't give you
warnings on a due reference so let's put
that to the test so literally a test
here I'm gonna say if Peter this is one
of the ways that I might fix it if Peter
middle name is null remember always
using is not double equals for null
tests unless you're absolutely certain
that there's no user defined override of
the equals operator better to use is it
always does a null check properly now if
it's null then return something else
let's say zero let's say that's the
default
you and now you see the warnings go away
because the compiler can see that if you
ever get here
then Peter middle name clearly wasn't
null so this is one way of fixing it but
either way you try will will have the
same effect if we move that and instead
we say I mean if you put the if in front
here and invert the condition that will
work too but let's try some more
creative ones let's use question dot for
instance let's read let's only do the
dereference if if the thing is not null
well now we get a different error saying
that we are not returning the right type
because that makes it nullable so I
guess we could go in and return the null
to the caller and then it's you can see
it's up to them to deal with now we're
in the nullable value type space here
and there's up to them to deal with the
fact that the length might be null but
if we want to keep it in the family here
keep it inside of the method then
another thing I could do well another
thing I could do is to use the null
coalescing operator and saying hey if
the left-hand is null then use zero
instead and now boom they all the
warnings go away and I have an int
that's either 0 if the thing was null or
that's the length if the thing was not
null and again the the compiler has is
tracking all the conditional logic here
and making sure that
hey you're not dereferencing anywhere
that you don't know the thing to be none
null so that's the core of the feature
the combination of the ability to
specify your intent is it null is it
supposed to be null or is it never
supposed to be null so you specify that
by having a question mark or not on your
reference type and then combine that
with the ability to check the usage of
everything that's declared in that way
and making sure that you use it
according to the declared intent you get
a warning if you if you put a null in
where you're not supposed to you get a
warning if you dereference something
that is not known not to be null that
might be known okay so and as you saw
this because this feature adds new
warnings we need to make it up tin in
some form because we can't just like
ship a new version of c-sharp and all of
a sudden you start getting new warnings
that's a breaking change
and people really do not like breaking
changes and we've been avoiding them so
far so let's keep doing that and so you
have to explicitly opt-in by somewhere
in your assembly specifying the module
level attribute nominal types you can
actually the the attribute is a little
more granular than that and if you if
you have like say let's say you have a
gigantic library lots of public surface
area and you kind of want to go
gradually opting into the whole
reference type is none null default on a
on a class-by-class basis for instance
you can put this attribute more
granularly on a class or even on a
method and you can even give it a false
argument to opt out for a certain scope
of code and that way sort of in a
transition period you don't have to sort
of own the whole nala bility problem for
all of your code at the same time you
can you can gradually roll into it so
that's it that's something we're sort of
finishing that a sign of right now and
there are also also sometimes methods
don't have like clear null ability
behave sometimes they have special
behavior with respect to null for
instance you know the is null or empty
method on string well it actually
guarantees that if it returns false and
the thing isn't null but there's no way
the compiler can know that by looking
from the outside and so we're also
fiddling with special attributes so you
can put on special methods and further
detail their null behavior until let
them tell you extra things about what
comes what goes in and what comes out so
that's all it's still in the works for
when this ships into char bait so that's
not reference types and that's probably
that's the feature that is most done and
also it's a very we think it's a very
potent feature and we're looking very
much forward to rolling it out so now
let's go back to slides and look at some
of the other features that we're
planning for CCR of 8 and then have a
little time for questions at the end
here so if we hop in here and go and
project that
and now the feature that we're we're
quite excited about is the ability to
better evolve interfaces so the features
called default interface members one of
the problems with interfaces is that you
can never add a new member to an
interface because all the existing
implementers will then be broken they
won't be implementing the new member so
once you have an interface and it's
published you're kind of stuck with it
and that's a little harsh so we want to
introduce a way that you can soften that
up a little bit and that's what default
interface members are for so in this
case here for instance I want to
introduce another overload of the log
method that on the interface so that
people have the option of implementing
that more efficiently for instance or
with different semantics and and the way
I get to do that without breaking
existing adopters of the interface of
existing implementers is that I specify
a default implementation so as a default
implementation here in terms of a method
body that uses the other members on the
interface to implement some sort of
default behavior and then my existing
console logger they're not affected at
all in fact we're going to put this into
the runtime so that they don't even have
to be recompiled they will just
automatically get the new member with
the default implementation when seen
from an assembly that knows about the
new member so run time make sure it's
there on the other hand though the the
the member can of course be implemented
then the default implementation just
doesn't doesn't play in at all so here
we are explicitly adding an
implementation of that interface member
and you just never knew there was an in
that case you never knew that wasn't a
default implementation so we think
that's a good feature for softening up
the evolution of interfaces and also
maybe I think you might think about
designing your interfaces a little
differently offering a few more methods
maybe then you usually would because you
don't have be quite a sparse you can
offer more members that have sort of
default implementation
and it's still as easy for implementers
to to implement the remaining behaviors
so that's that one another thing that
we've been looking at for a while is
that there's sort of sort of a hole in
our story around a sink if you will we
introduced a sink to the language in
c-sharp 5 and that's the notion there in
the framework of a task of T task of int
for instance task of string which is
essentially an asynchronous result it's
something that you can await and then at
some point in the future it will produce
a single value that then the await
language feature lets you consume right
there and continue your code from where
you left it when you decided to await
that thing earlier but it only works for
single values and a lot of what happens
asynchronously these days is actually
more like asynchronous streaming so you
have a continuous stream of data either
like a limited one that just comes in
multiple chunks for efficiency over the
wire or maybe you know a stream from an
IOT device or something that will
continue to give you values and at a
given interval or random and you need
better ways to consume that as well and
so we want to support a notion of
asynchronous streams essentially an
asynchronous version of ienumerable
which is something that can be for
reached so we're introducing ia sig
enumerable and you can you can for each
await those so there's a new version of
for each that will consume ia sync
enumerables and automatically for an
asynchronous stream automatically halt
the loop until the next value is
available in an asynchronous manner
inside of an async method we're also not
shown here but we're also going to
update iterators these things that can
produce I know Mobile's today by doing
yield return we're going to also make a
version of that that can produce ia sync
and no more goals in the same manner so
language support for these asynchronous
streams and then as a sort of very
related point another thing that you
can't do
synchronously today is disposal you have
the I disposable interface and it forces
you to have a synchronous dispose method
well what if disposal includes like
closing a file or something that's
inherently async and you want you know
when you have a using clause you want to
wait after the using Clause ends you
want to wait for that all to have happen
you want to know that disposal is
complete it's not a really good
mechanism for that today so we're gonna
also introduce is Inc disposable as an
interface and using a weight as a
mechanism to consume an asynchronously
disposable object and it'll work exactly
the same way it awaits the disposal
there's gonna be a dispose async method
in there somewhere it weights that at
the end of the using so that the next
line after won't be executed until that
all that asynchronous disposal has
happened so that's the async story that
we're looking at and there's still
questions in there around how far do we
go with async link and stuff like that
on top of the I think you know mobile
that's all being worked out also for
c-sharp 8 and again is it this all
happens in the open you can go and see
the state of the implementations you can
go and see the state of the discussion
the length design notes and so on online
another feature that was a really good
start I think and kind of covered the
80% scenario in c-sharp 7 but could
definitely be refined is its pattern
matching so we introduced patterns since
he shared 7 but they're more things you
could definitely do with them patterns
patterns today can either be used in an
is expression or they can be used in an
good old-fashioned switch statement well
a switch statement is great it lets you
go through all the options one by one
but syntactically it's a bit of a bear
it's like 50-year old syntax from from C
that has been carefully carried over
from language to language and so it's
kind of clunky and one of the things we
want to do is introduce a switch
expression that's just sort of like the
zipi version of that that doesn't have
all that as in tactic goo and this is
this is roughly what it's going to look
like
so I'm going to so the expression form
switch is an infix operator between oh
the object that I'm going to switch on
and then a bunch of cases here which
don't have the case keyword because
that's fluff they just have a pattern
followed by a and lambda arrow followed
by the expression for what is that was
what are we going to produce out of the
whole expression if this pattern matches
so we just go through an order like in a
switch statement is it an int then call
it AI and return this string here is it
a point then here is another thing that
we want to improve with with patterns
which is recursive patterns if it's a
point then deconstruct a point according
to its D constructor which again a
feature we add in C sharp 7 and then
apply these nested patterns recursively
to the values that came out of
deconstructing that point so a point
comes in we deconstruct it we get two
values if they're both intz then they
satisfy this pattern and then call them
x and y and x and y i can then be used
in the expression that produces a result
of the pattern and so on and of course
there's a discard that you can also use
and that means you don't need the
default keyword in here either so that's
one thing or rather two things the match
expressions or switch expressions and
the recursive patterns there and then
all a sort of special version of the
recursive pattern that I think is going
to be quite useful I don't know why I
have the match keyword there that's a
slight copy-paste fail but switching on
tuples and being able to match with with
tuple patterns here as well so that
takes us pretty much to the end there's
the c-sharp lang repo is where all the
language design discussion happens we
can go and take a quick look at it in a
minute there's a wiki there where
sometimes there are links to prototypes
they don't quite work with current
versions of Visual Studio right now but
we update them from time to time and
then you can try some of the very early
versions of the features at once that we
are like still tinkering with
but also participate in the life sign
discussion and so on and the docs that I
mentioned before Doc's that Microsoft
had come has brilliant ducks for c-sharp
that follow along the new versions very
quickly in particular if you go to the
what's new on the C sharp you get the
latest versions and all the features
that are in there so I want to just
quickly before we take it over to QA
just show you that github site the
c-sharp lang site here so this is where
language design happens the documents
that we use for designing c-sharp are
all kept here in the open where
everybody can see them the and the
discussion is here in in the issues
where everybody can participate so you
can see the source code in this repo is
is actually documents here are all the
meeting notes from all the c-sharp
language design meetings dating all the
way back to 2013 if we go into 2018 you
can see there's some pretty recent ones
down here here's the one from September
5th and you can just go and see what did
we discuss and you can go and have an
opinion about it if you go to the issues
there various things to look out for
most generally generally there's a lot
of discussions in here but we also track
features to milestones and here if you
look for the label that is proposal
champion that means that this is a
proposal that someone on the language
design team thinks that we should look
into and so that's a really good label
to filter forward to see what is
currently being considered by the
c-sharp language design team and if you
then wonder about well what's the
current timeframe for considering it you
can go and further you can go and look
at the milestones that are c-sharp
versions essentially so for instance the
things that are currently considered for
going into c-sharp eight c sharp eight
oh and these ones here and not all of
them are going to happen like we
generally have a lot more in these
milestones and will actually end up
shipping and that's the milestone is
more like an indicator of why
do we think it's a good time to have the
discussion and and make a decision and
then the decision might be we actually
don't want to do this or we'll do it
later then we change the milestone and
so on so that's just to that community
aspect of c-sharp language design and
giving you sort of inviting you in here
for the many of you that have never gone
there come in and have a look you don't
need to be a language wonk and you don't
need to participate in all the heated
discussions you can quickly get sort of
just an impression of what's going on in
there and I really recommend that you do
that and with that let's go over to the
Q&A I think we have another 9 minutes or
so for QA so I'm going to see if I can
see what's up on the screen up here and
then take some questions so here's one
are there any new c-sharp capabilities
especially useful for data science
that's a really good one
this data science in general machine
learning in particular which you know
some would say is this particular branch
of data science that's something that we
have generally not been good at in
c-sharp and in dotnet and we're rapidly
getting better you if you if you hurt
the keynote you heard about ml net where
we're going very actively after having
great machine learning frameworks in net
and so how does C sharp C sharp stack up
here well it has a few things from old
it has operator overloading for instance
but in general it's not very good and so
there are definitely things that we're
looking at doing one thing that's
particularly good for large datasets is
the arrangement index feature as I
showed before they're going to make it
much easier to to manipulate those large
chunks of data together with span and
everything that's already in there
there's also things that we're
considering but that are particularly
difficult because they will need
significant runtime changes as well one
of the things that's hard in almost in
almost all programming languages is a
good type safe way to abstract over
numerics
I want to write in a generic algorithm
that works for everything that has a
plus and a zero static property for
instance like how can you how can you
write a generic constraint that says
something that has a plus and and a zero
property a static zero property well we
don't have that today and we're looking
into various ways of providing good
numeric abstraction maybe through
allowing interfaces to have static
members and operators or things like
that so but that's probably on a mem on
a slightly longer track but that's just
a few of the things that we can
definitely do better at the language
level also we can always improve
computation speed looking at targeting
GPUs and so on and that's all work that
we're we're looking at and hopefully
you'll see us move on over the next
couple years in a big way okay Igor asks
will we ever get a bit more verbose null
reference exception that will include
information about what variable was
actually null well if you if you use the
debugger in Visual Studio it will tell
you exactly what variable was null so we
we did that as a as an IDE feature that
you know will will tell you right things
as long as you were inside of the
framework of Visual Studio now couldn't
we do this at runtime even when you get
those runtime those null reference
exceptions in production well that's
much harder because now we're talking
about information that's not actually
stored anywhere and we would have to
like store a lot of extra information in
those lean mean production and
assemblies in order to get that so I
don't know that we'll get that but as
long as you do it in the debugger in
Visual Studio you got that okay what can
you tell us about the async streams
feature also so I pretty much told you
what I could how does it relate to the
reactive streams work being done in the
community so that's a really good
question so for those people who aren't
familiar with reactive streams the idea
of reactive well yeah the idea of an
unknowable or am ia sink enumerable is
the
there pull collections you get a new
element when you ask for it so you pull
four elements okay
reactive is the push kind of framework
where you give it essentially you give
your collection a call back and it will
call the call back back whenever there's
a new element so it's pushing
information to the call back and that's
sort of two opposites and they they it
affects the direction that you compose
them in if you will so so Poole has the
problem that consumption needs to happen
at the you know at the speed of the
consumer so somehow the producer needs
to make values available when you're
ready for that async is better because
it's a little better there because you
the consumer is at least willing to wait
around until the value is there
asynchronously push has the opposite
problem that it happens at the speed of
the producer and the the stream of
values might easily choke consumers that
they just can't process the values
coming at them fast enough and so you
can mate you could also in parallel have
an async reactive framework that would
kind of hold back the producer but
here's the thing there's an asymmetry
where this oftentimes one producer but
many consumers and so should one
consumer hold the producer back so that
the and and thereby slow down the other
consumer isn't there's a difficult
problem there but I think that
the two can be adapted between quite
well through a framework so if you have
something that's reactive and that
produces values we can build adapter
types that turn those into asynchronous
streams that you can then depending on
what adapter you choose your your
consumption experience can either like
buffer any elements that are produced in
the meantime or the last n or you can
keep just the last value or not even
that it can just a synchronously wait
for the next value to come around
whenever you look around so I think
there's a way to deal with that okay one
more question here will the end of
collection operator the hat operator
work as a reverse index or count from
end in other words to get the last
element in an array will I use my array
hat 0 or my array hat 1
the answer is you'll use my array hat 1
so it is it essentially does work like
as if you set count minus the number and
count minus 0 is count and that's off
the end of an array and the way you
would use hat 0 is as the is at the at
the end point of a range expression
because the range is exclusive at the
end so hat 0 would point correctly to
the element after the last one so that's
that's where you would see hat 0 being
used and that's one of the reasons why
we didn't go with minus or something
like that because then you'd want to be
able to distinguish 0 and minus 0 and
those are really hard to distinguish
that's pretty much it for time I think
and there are no more questions up there
so at least that I can see on the screen
so with that I want to say thank you
very much for listening in either live
or at the leisure of your own time and
go play with the the latest C sharp
features keep an eye out for C sharp 8
and tried the previews as soon as they
come out and tell us what you think
tell us online because we're there and
we're eager to hear and heed your
feedback thank you very much